>>> GOOD EVENING.
TONIGHT TWO BIG LEGAL SETBACKS
FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
A FEDERAL JUDGE ORDERING HIS
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PAT
CIPOLLONE AND DEPUTY TO GIVE
CRIMINAL TESTIMONY TO THE GRAND
JURY INVESTIGATING THE JANUARY
6th.
ALSO FLAT-OUT REJECTING THE NEED
FOR A SPECIAL MASTER TO REVIEW
DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
THE 11th CIRCUIT APPEALS PANEL
STATING FORMERLY FORMER
PRESIDENTS SHOULD NOT RECEIVE
SPECIAL TREATMENT.
I'M QUOTING FROM THE OPINION, IN
CONSIDERING THESE ARGUMENTS, WE
ARE FACED WITH A CHOICE, APPLY
OUR USUAL TEST, DRASTICALLY
EXPAND THE AVAILABILITY OF
EQUITABLE JURISDICTION OF EVERY
SUBJECT OF A SEARCH WARRANT, OR
CARVE OUT AN UNPRECEDENTED
EXCEPTION IN OUR LAW FOR FORMER
PRESIDENTS.
WE CHOOSE THE FIRST OPTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, FORMER PRESIDENT
OR NOT, THE NORMAL RULES APPLY.
CNN'S SARA MURRAY JOINS US WITH
MORE ON THIS AND THE CIPOLLONE
CASE.
SARA, WHAT DOES THIS MEAN THE
COURT RULING ON THE MAR-A-LAGO
DOCUMENTS?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR THE DOJ
AND THEIR INVESTIGATION?
>> OBVIOUSLY, IT'S A BIG WIN FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WHO
HAD BEEN ARGUING THERE SHOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN A SPECIAL MASTER IN
THIS CASE ALL ALONG.
PRACTICALLY, IT COULD MEAN THAT
THEY WILL GET THIS WHOLE MESS OF
DOCUMENTS SOONER THAN THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE.
REMEMBER, THEY ALREADY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE ROUGHLY 100
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE MARKED
CLASSIFIED.
BUT THERE WERE THOUSANDS OF
THESE OTHER DOCUMENTS THAT THEY
WANT TO TRY TO USE TO MAKE THEIR
CASE ABOUT HOW THINGS WERE
STORED HAPHAZARDLY AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
SO NOW THEY COULD GET THEM
SOONER.
OF COURSE, THE X FACTOR WILL
TRUMP APPEAL?
WE'VE SEEN HIS WILLINGNESS TO DO
SO MANY, MANY RELATED CASES.
HE EARLIER APPEAL SOMETHING TO
THE SUPREME COURT AND HE MAY
ULTIMATELY DECIDE TO GO TO THE
SUPREME COURT WITH THIS QUESTION
AS WELL.
WE SHOULD NOTE, THOUGH, THAT
THIS APPEALS COURT THAT RULED
AGAINST THE TRUMP TEAM TODAY, IT
IS MADE UP OF THREE GOP
APPOINTED JUDGES, ANDERSON.
>> SO IF HE DID WANT TO SLOW
THINGS DOWN, HE COULD TRY TO
APPEAL TO THE SUPREME COURT?
>> HE COULD, YES.
IF HE STILL WANTS TO TRY TO
STALL, HE COULD GO TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
HE COULD ASK FOR SOME
INTERVENTION THERE.
HE COULD GO BACK TO THIS COURT,
FRANKLY, AND ASK FOR THE ENTIRE
PANEL TO HEAR IT.
SO HE COULD ASK THEM TO HEAR IT
ON BUNK, ALTHOUGH I'M NOT SURE
WHY YOU WOULD DO THAT, GIVEN THE
PANEL POSSIBLY SYMPATHETIC
J-RIDGES THEY HAD AND HOW THEY
RULED AGAINST THEM.
>> CIPOLLONE HAS BEEN ORDERED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY BEFORE THE GRAND
JURY INVESTIGATING THE EFFORTS
TO INTERFERE WITH THE ELECTION.
HE ALREADY APPEARED BACK IN
SEPTEMBER.
IT WAS OBVIOUSLY BEFORE THE
COUNSEL JACK SMITH WAS APPOINTED
TO OVERSEE THE DOJ PROBE.
WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED IS A JUDGE
RULED THAT CIPOLLONE AS WELL AS
HIS DEPUTY PAT PHILBIN HAD TO GO
BECOME TO THE GRAND JURY AND
TESTIFY.
NOW, AGAIN, THIS IS ALL
HAPPENING BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
THIS IS A SECRET COURT
PROCEEDING.
AND TRUMP'S TEAM HAD ARGUED
BECAUSE OF PRIVILEGE ISSUES THEY
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO ANSWER
CERTAIN QUESTIONS FOR THE GRAND
JURY.
NOW THE QUESTION IS ARE THESE
GUYS GOING TO GET SWEPT INTO THE
GRAND JURY QUICKLY, OR WILL
TRUMP'S TEAM FIRST APPEAL BEFORE
THEY GO BACK THERE?
WE DO EXPECT AN APPEAL BY THE
TRUMP TEAM.
WE'LL SEE WAIT AND SEE HOY THIS
PLAYS OUT.
THIS IS HAPPENING BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS SO WE'RE LEARNING THIS
FROM PEOPLE BRIEF ON THE MATTER.
>> THIS IS A GRAND JURY PROBE
FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS THE CRIMINAL GRAND JURY
PROBE HAVING TO DO WITH EFFORTS
TO OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION.
REMEMBER, THESE GUYS WITHER IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY WERE AROUND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE THERE WHEN HE WAS
RAISING SCHEMES ABOUT TRYING TO
GO TO STATES, WHEN HE WAS
SUGGESTING THIS POTENTIAL COUP
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO THEY HAVE OBVIOUSLY SEEN A
LOT.
>> SARA MURRAY, APPRECIATE IT.
I WANT TO GET SOME PERSPECTIVE
NOW.
OUR TWO CNN LEGAL ANALYSTS ELLIE
CARRIE CORDERO AND ELIE HONIG.
HOW HELPFUL IS THIS TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
INVESTIGATION GOING FORWARD?
>> I THINK THE 11th CIRCUIT
RULING IS IMPORTANT IN THE CASE.
WHAT IT DID IT IS BASICALLY SAID
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS NOT
ENTITLED TO SPECIAL TREATMENT,
THAT EXECUTING SEARCH WARRANTS
IS A STANDARD PROCESS FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, FOR THE FBI
WHEN THEY'RE CONDUCTING AN
INVESTIGATION.
THAT WHEN THAT WARRANT IS BASED
ON PROBABLE CAUSE AND IT'S
APPROVED BY A JUDGE, THAT THERE
REALLY WERE NO STRONG ARGUMENTS
MADE BY THE FORMER PRESIDENT
THAT A SPECIAL MASTER SHOULD BE
IN PLACE AND THAT HE SHOULD
RECEIVE ANY SPECIAL TREATMENT.
SO I THINK THE 11th CIRCUIT CASE
AND THE OPINION THAT WAS JUST
ISSUED REALLY RESETS THIS CASE
IN TERMS OF THE WAY THINGS
NORMALLY WOULD WORK FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THE SUBJECT OF
A SEARCH IN ANY INVESTIGATION
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> ELIE, HOW DO YOU SEE THE
OPINION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THIS OPINION IS
ABOUT JURISDICTION.
MEANING THE COURTS JUST CAN'T DO
ANYTHING THEY FEEL LIKE.
WHAT THE COURT OF APPEALS TODAY
SAID IS THE DISTRICT COURT, IN
ORDERING THE SPECIAL MASTER WENT
TOO FAR.
THAT'S NOT A THING THAT COURTS
CAN DO.
YOU CANNOT INTERFERE WITH A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION AT THIS
STAGE.
AND AS A PRACTICAL MATTER WHAT
THIS DOES IS IT REMOVES A
ROADBLOCK OR A SPEED BUMP FOR
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
IT MEANS UNLESS THIS CASE GOES
UP TO THE SUPREME COURT AND GETS
REVERSED, WHICH I THINK IS VERY,
VERY UNLIKELY, DOJ CAN NOW TAKE
ALL THE DOCUMENTS THEY SEIZED AT
MAR-A-LAGO AND USE THEM FULLY IN
THEIR INVESTIGATION.
SO IT WILL ENABLE THE DOJ TO
CARRY ON WITH THEIR
INVESTIGATION IN A SPEEDY
MANNER.
>> DAVID, JUST IN TERMS OF THE
LEGAL STRATEGY, DO YOU THINK IT
WAS A MISTAKE NOW FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM TO GO
THROUGH THE ROUTE OF REQUESTING
A SPECIAL MASTER, OR IF GUMMING
UP THE WORKS OR SLOWING DOWN THE
PROCESS WAS THE GOAL, WAS THAT
SUCCESSFUL?
>> ANDERSON, I THINK WE'VE HAD
THIS DISCUSSION BEFORE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS ONE
IDEA AND HIS LEGAL TEAM HAVE A
SEPARATE IDEA, AND HE IS THE
CLIENT.
I THINK THEY FILED THIS SUIT.
FACIALLY THEY HAD A CLAIM.
AND AS HAS BEEN POINTED OUT BY
THE 11th CIRCUIT, THERE ARE
THREE JUDGES ON THE 11th
CIRCUIT.
THEY DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
STANDING TO DO SO FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS, SEPARATION OF POWERS
AND OTHERS.
I ANTICIPATE THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM WILL
APPEAL ASKING TO BE HELD BY THE
ENTIRE 11th CIRCUIT WHICH
SUCCESS SEEMS PRETTY SLIM AND
THEN THEY'LL APPEAL TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
IT'S A TACTIC KYIV SEEN BEFORE
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS IN
TERMS OF JUST DELAY.
AND I THINK THAT THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO DELAY UNTIL THE
ABSOLUTE LAST MOMENT THEY CAN,
AND THE SUPREME COURT DOESN'T
TAKE IT UP.
I DON'T THINK THE SUPREME COURT
WILL TAKE IT UP.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THEY'LL TAKE TO
IT THE 11th CIRCUIT EN BANC AND
WE'LL SEE WHAT THEY SAY.
>> CARRIE, HOW LONG COULD IT
SLOW THINGS DOWN?
THE RULING BY THE 11th CIRCUIT
DOESN'T GO INTO EFFECT FOR SEVEN
DAYS, WHICH OBVIOUSLY GIVES THE
PRESIDENT TIME THERE.
>> RIGHT.
SO IT GIVES HIM TIME TO APPEAL.
AND SO THEN THERE WILL BE A
DETERMINATION WHETHER OR NOT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CAN GO AHEAD
AND ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
INFORMATION.
SO THERE IS SOME I THINK A
LITTLE BIT OF AMBIGUITY AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN START
LOOKING AT THE INFORMATION RIGHT
AWAY, OR WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT A LITTLE
WHILE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
CREDIBLE BASIS FOR THE EN BANC
APPELLATE COURT OR FOR THE
SUPREME COURT TO TAKE UP THE
ARGUMENTS IN THIS CASE.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT JUST HOW UNUSUAL THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S ARGUMENTS
WERE IN THIS CASE.
THE NORMAL TIME THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL WOULD CHALLENGE THE
RESULTS OF A SEARCH AND SAY THAT
THEIR RIGHTS HAD BEEN VIOLATED
IS WHEN THEY'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
CHARGED WITH SOMETHING.
SO THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
LEGAL STRATEGY REALLY JUMPED FAR
FORWARD HERE BY TRYING TO MAKE
ARGUMENTS THAT HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS WERE BEING
ABUSED IN SOME WAY BY THE WAY
THAT THE FBI HANDLED THIS SEARCH
THAT JUST IS NOT THE WAY THAT
NORMAL INVESTIGATIONS WOULD WORK
IN ANY OTHER MATTER.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> I'LL JUST SAY IT'S CLEARLY A
SETBACK FOR THE PRESIDENT IN ANY
WAY YOU LOOK AT IT.
>> ELIE, IF THE FORMER PRESIDENT
IS EVENTUALLY CHARGED WITH THE
CRIME, WOULD HE HAVE ANOTHER
CHANCE TO CHALLENGE THE SEARCH
WARRANT THEN, TO CARRIE'S POINT?
>> YES, HE WOULD, ANDERSON.
THAT'S PRECISELY FOR THE COURT'S
OPINION TODAY.
THEY SAY ESSENTIALLY YOU'RE NOT
SPECIAL.
THEY SAY LOOK, WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF CHOICES HERE.
WE COULD SAY EVERYBODY GETS A
SPECIAL MASTER AFTER A SEARCH.
WELL DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
WE COULD SAY NOBODY GETS A
SPECIAL MASTER AFTER THE SEARCH,
WHICH IS THE NORMAL RULE, OR
ONLY FORMER PRESIDENTS.
THEY SAY WE'RE NOT DOING THAT.
THE WAY IT NORMALLY WORKS,
ANDERSON, IF THERE COMES A DAY
WHERE DONALD TRUMP OR ANYBODY
GETS INDICTED AND THEY WANT TO
CHALLENGE THE SEARCH WARRANT, AT
THAT POINT THE PROSECUTORS WILL
HAVE TO GIVE THEM ALL THE
DOCUMENTS, ALL THE PAPERWORK
THAT WENT TO THE JUDGE.
AND YOU CAN, AND I'M SURE IF
THIS EVER HAPPENS, DONALD TRUMP
WILL CHALLENGE THE SEARCH.
HE'LL SAY IT WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
HE'LL SAY THAT THE PROSECUTORS
DID NOT ESTABLISH PROBABLE
CAUSE, THAT THE SEARCH VIOLATED
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
AND IF HE WINS AT THAT POINT,
THEN THE EVIDENCE CANNOT BE USED
AGAINST HIM.
BUT THAT'S THE WAY THIS NORMALLY
WORKS.
>> THE FACT THAT NOW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAYS HE IS RUNNING
AGAIN FOR ANOTHER TERM, I MEAN,
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF TALK
THAT MAYBE HE THINKS BY
ANNOUNCING THAT MIGHT SLOW DOWN
SOME OF THE INVESTIGATIONS OR AT
LEAST COMPLICATE THEM AND MAKE
THEM LOOK POLITICAL.
DO YOU THINK THIS RULING IN ANY
WAY AFFECTS HIS RUN?
>> ANDERSON, I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE TOUGH TO MAKE CASE WHEN
YOU HAD THREE REPUBLICANS, THE
JUDGES THAT ISSUED -- THE
CIRCUIT JUDGES THAT ISSUED THIS
OPINION ARE A BUSH APPOINTEE AND
TWO TRUMP APPOINTEES.
IT'S PRETTY TOUGH TO MAKE THAT
CASE.
OBVIOUSLY, A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES BELIEVE THAT THIS
CASE WAS FLAWED IN THE BEGINNING
BECAUSE OF SEPARATION OF POWERS
ARGUMENT, RIGHT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT -- THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH SHOULDN'T BE
INTERFERING IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH'S BUSINESS.
PRETTY TOUGH.
>> CARRIE, I GOT A DUMB QUESTION
FOR YOU.
NOTE THAT ALL MINE AREN'T DUMB.
BUT WHEN THE JUDGMENT OF A U.S.
DISTRICT JUDGE IN THIS CASE
AILEEN CANNON IS COMPLETELY
OVERTURNED BY A FEDERAL APPEALS
COURT, IS THERE ANY CAREER OR
REPUTATIONAL HARM TO THE JUDGE?
LIKE THE NEXT DAY IN THE JUDGE'S
CHAMBERS OR THE JUDGE'S COFFEE
BREAK ROOM ARE, THE OTHER JUDGES
LIKE WOW, THAT WAS LAME?
IS THERE ANY BLOWBACK?
>> THIS CASE IS UNUSUAL BECAUSE
IT INVOLVES A FORMER PRESIDENT.
SO, YOU KNOW, THERE CERTAINLY
COULD BE THE COFFEE CHATTER
ABOUT IT.
BUT LOOK, JUDGES GET OVERTURNED.
I MEAN, THAT'S HOW WE HAVE AN
APPELLATE SYSTEM.
THAT'S HOW CASES END UP GOING UP
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
SO IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, IT'S
VERY HIGH PROFILE, OBVIOUSLY.
IN MY JUDGMENT, AND OBVIOUSLY IN
THE 11 CIRCUIT'S JUDGMENT, THE
ORIGINAL JUDGE'S OPINION WAS NOT
BASED ON THE LAW AND WAS NOT
WELL REASONED.
BUT JUDGES GET OVERTURNED.
THAT'S BASICALLY HOW THE SYSTEM
IS SET UP TO WORK.
>> YOU SAID THAT IN A VERY NICE
WAY.
THE JUDG